President Trump has fashioned himself as one
of the decade's biggest villains in a confusing
new campaign clip.
The video – released by a Twitter account
called @TrumpWarRoom, which itself is reportedly
managed by the Trump 2020 campaign superimposes
Trump's grinning face onto footage of Thanos
in Avengers: Endgame during one of the villain's
final scenes.
In the clip, two different versions of Trump's
head admire Thanos' Infinity Gauntlet before
Brolin's voice utters, "I am inevitable."
Right after President Thanos' proclamation,
the video switches to a clip of Speaker of
the House Nancy Pelosi discussing the ongoing
Trump impeachment inquiry – only for her
and several other high-ranking Democrats to
promptly get "dusted."
Trump's team captioned the video,
"House Democrats can push their sham impeachment
all they want.
President Trump's re-election is inevitable."
This tweet comes on the heels of the announcement
that House Democrats will charge the President
with two articles of impeachment specifically,
"abuse of power and obstruction of Congress"
which, if it proceeds, would make Trump the
third sitting President in United States history
to face impeachment.
All of this makes the video a pretty confusing
take on Trump's political future, and it leads
one to wonder whether or not Trump's team
has even seen Avengers: Endgame.
Firstly, there's the fact that Thanos is,
frankly, a genocidal maniac who kills his
adopted daughter for his own gain and decimates
half of the living creatures on Earth.
Certainly, Trump's team wouldn't want to liken
the President to such a villainous character
if they're trying to get him re-elected.
Secondly, the Endgame moment that follows
the one used in this campaign clip doesn't
exactly work out well for Thanos.
Though the tweet makes it look like Trump-Thanos
is about to achieve victory, anyone who's
seen Endgame knows what really happens is
quite the opposite.
It appears Trump's team may not have realized
this, which makes the depiction of Trump as
Thanos extra confusing.
"He's pretty good at that.”
This isn't the first time that the President
and his team have used a super-popular piece
of entertainment to push forward his 2020
re-election campaign.
Back in April 2019 when the final season of
Game of Thrones was dominating the pop culture
landscape, Trump uploaded to his Twitter account
an image using Thrones' instantly recognizable
font.
The photo showed the President's back with
the caption, "No collusion.
No obstruction.
For the haters and the radical left Democrats
— Game Over."
The meme arrived right after the redacted
Mueller report which documents the findings
of former U.S. Special Counsel Robert Mueller's
investigation into possible Russian interference
in the 2016 U.S. election, as well as other
allegations of obstruction of justice by President
Trump first made the news.
Game of Thrones' network HBO wasted no time
responding to Trump's tweet.
In a statement released by Deadline, the network
replied,
"Though we can understand the enthusiasm for
Game of Thrones now that the final season
has arrived, we still prefer our intellectual
property not be used for political purposes."
This was HBO's most civil response to President
Trump to date.
In November 2018, Trump used the Game of Thrones
font for an image that read "sanctions are
coming" in a clear, direct reference to Thrones'
famous tagline, "winter is coming" to which
HBO cheekily tweeted,
"How do you say trademark misuse in Dothraki?"
However, the President's Thrones references
were only getting started.
In January 2019, Trump carried out the same
trick on his Instagram account, this time
noting that "the wall is coming" rather than
"sanctions."
Unsurprisingly, plenty of people weren't too
happy with that one either.
This latest effort hasn't sparked any pushback
from Marvel just yet, but all in all, the
Trump-as-Thanos video sends a pretty muddled
message since Thanos isn't a sympathetic figure,
ends up losing Endgame's biggest battle, and
then dies.
Even in these politically fraught times, most
people can probably agree that pop culture
and politics should remain separate after
all, where can you escape the news if not
at a screening of a Marvel flick? but Trump's
latest attempt is definitely worth some discussion.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.